[Applause]
it is time to talk parenting trends and
understanding kids as i momsplain it all
maybe little nas x is headed back to
country music his debut album montero
just debuted last friday but now he's
trending because of his dedication to
dolly the grammy winner performed a
cover of dolly parton's iconic 1973 hit
jolene during an appearance at bbc radio
1 live lounge and the internet is
screaming check it out
[Music]
the two are actually fans of each other
dolly said that she did have the
opportunity to be on lil nazak's
breakout hit old town road but she
turned it down since he already remixed
the track with other artists like bts
billy ray cyrus and lil wayne but dolly
says she does hope she can work with him
on another project in the future
up next is tech making it harder to
parent a new study says that parents
think so the study by one poll found
that four in five parents agree it's
harder to raise children today than when
they were growing up and aiden 10 agree
parenting is more challenging than 30
years ago due to the role that
technology plays in our everyday lives
and 86 percent of parents say that kids
grow up much faster today thanks to tech
time to step away from the tablet and
finally it's fall and pumpkin spice
latte season has already been around for
a couple of weeks but now pumpkin has
hit your luscious locks the fall color
pumpkin cream is going to be a huge
trend this season pumpkin cream mixes
shades of orange and copper with blonde
highlights now this is different than
the pumpkin
spice hair color that trend mixes shades
of orange and brown for a deeper color
this one it's lighter and well creamier
everyone from dua lipa to sizza have
jumped on this trend so it's probably
going to stick around for a while so now
you can order a pcl pumpkin cream locks
the next time you get your hair done and
now you've had a mom's playing